المسؤوليه طبعا كبرت تتكلم اليوم عن رياضه
كبيره رياضه لها
نوعيات مختلفه وقت ما اصبح لي انا يعني
حتى لو كان عندي وقت صغير لكن في نفس
الوقت لما اتصل بي صديق مثل
عندنا عضو في المجلس العالمي لرياضه
السيارات واا رجل همم اثر له تاثير على
المنطقه همم طبعا قلت اجي واا اجرب
السياره واتمتع بنوع من همم في السياره
بنوع من الاثاره بعد ما اقدر هي رياضه
السيارات وجذوره هي همم
انا همم كنت قائد اللي همم لتاريخ كبير
فيها فما اقدر انساها
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
قديم نحن التغيرات اللي انا بديت فيها ما
تقدر تغير الاتحاد الاتحاد كبير وعمره 118
سنه في خلال شهر او شهرين او سنه اولا انا
لازم اسمع للناس اسمع للفريق اشوف الاغلاق
ونطوره اكبر تحديات كانت عندنا
الامور الماليه كان الاتحاد في خساره لمده
ثلاث سنوات وحتى الميزانيه اللي كانت ل22
كانت في خساره والحمد لله صلحنا كثير فيها
هذا كان كبر تحدي هي الله يسترك ما يسمى
هذا الشيء كبير انا مع الحكمه ولكن مش مع
الحكمه لما اكون همم تكون الحكمه متى ما
انا اريد يعني عرفت كيف الحكمه لازم تكون
طول الوقت مش همم بس اني ارفع علمها الشيء
الثالث تحديات وامور معلقه خاصه في
المحاكم الدوليه والحمد لله حليناها كانت
بتاثر على على مسيره الميزانيه الاتحاد
بشيء جذري انا بكل فخر اقول ان من شهر
حلينا هذه المشكله والحين صار لعب اللي
كان على ظهر كان الحين اقل تقويه الانديه
هو الاتحادات في العالم وهمم تقويه
الاقليمات يعني همم
بيكون هذا الشيء التحدي اعطاء ال- ال-
الفرصه اللي همم الشباب سواء كان في اي
مكان في العالم همم سيارات اقل تكلفه من
السيارات اللي موجوده وخاصه اليوم ان احنا
ناخذ
تصميم سياره وانا اعطيهم في كل بلد او في
كل جزء من نساء العالم وهما بعدين يطورون
السياره طبعا هذا لازم يكون بالمظله
وبيحمايه قالونيه
هي مهمه هي اساس رياضه السيارات وهي الدخل
الكبير همم قوانين نصلح فيها وفي كانت
اغلاط احنا همم انا ورثته واتحاد ورثه
ولكن الحين في التطوير والتطوير حتى
القوانين اللي عنا يا اخي هذا هذا مش كتاب
مقدس عندنا احنا وكتاب من الله القوانين
تتطور كتبها انسان يطورها انسان ويصلح
فيها انسان